locked down everyone's been playing more
games right i found a game
where
uh i hadn't picked it up for i don't
know 20 years do you recognize this
brady
that's past the pigs did you have a copy
of this yes in its faux leather case
plastic for anyone who hasn't played
this game is ridiculously simple and i
can't quite
believe that it's a good game when it's
just to roll the pigs
but what i'd like to do in this video is
sort of remind everyone how it works
i'll show you if you haven't seen it and
also we can we can do some proper
mathematical modelling on this which
surprised me and i quite enjoyed it so
that's the plan so the pigs uh are just
they're just plastic pigs and maybe i
can plant them here is that on your
camera okay there's a dot on one side
and not on the other but there's just
two of them they're plastic pigs they're
not real pigs and the idea is you roll
them and you score some points now this
is a very exciting role there are some
scores here how they land
just give you some some points so
according to this uh this one's called a
razorback because the landlord's backs
would give me five points i'm not going
to go into details like the rules are
here and again you just roll the pigs
you score some points and that's it
which does not make it a good game until
you realize you do have a decision to
make which is you can roll again at any
point like i've scored some points i can
roll again
and i score some more points and i can
keep rolling as many times as i like
unless i roll
on the next time i roll i roll this
particular configuration where one dot
up
one no dot and that's called pig out and
i lose my points so that's that's the
end of my turn it's not the end of the
game it's just the end of my turn and at
that point i passed the pigs so you sort
of stick or twist hoping not to bust out
back or bust stick or twist roll or hold
whatever you want it's that dichotomy
the only decision you're making is
actually
do i roll again
or does that feel too greedy so the risk
is actually it's a simple decision but
it's not obvious how to play well the
trouble is with this game is it's really
hard to analyze how to play well because
pigs are notoriously difficult to
predict how they land like it's not
obvious to me the probability of landing
like this or landing like that or
the best role i think is called a
leaning a leaning jowler where it's on
its ear and it's chin great but i have
no idea the probability of rolling that
so for the sake of analysis and this is
what i like to think of mathematicians
doing the modeling cycle you basically
let's just make it simpler so we can
analyze it and then we'll come back
to upgrade for the real thing
so i'm going to remove the pigs for now
but they'll come back and we'll replace
the pigs with a single d6 regular d6 and
in this game
same idea
you just roll the dive and whatever it
lands on you score and you then choose
to roll again or bank
and the catch like in the other one is
that this time if you roll a one at any
point
that's the end of your turn and you pass
the dice to the next person so that's it
and actually this is the original game
as far as i can find it's been around
for a long time it's called pig which i
presume is where they got the name pasta
pigs from and they just let's make some
lovely pigs and boom
millions of pounds later everyone's
happy with the plastic pigs get but the
original d6 roller one you lose your
points pass it on otherwise you bank at
any point let's have a game ready all
right i'm actually going to have two
columns for each of us and one will be a
running total wanna be just the points
he's going this time so uh you're going
to go first here we go you ready yeah
that's a four now you can roll again or
you can bank it i'm gonna roll again i
think you should all right but don't let
me tell you what to do all right i want
more points four what's good though
four's a good score that's better than
one i need lost
so you get a zero for that turn and
you're talking about zero that was
greedy yeah you agreed some if i first
learned this game with the dice and i
called it greedy pig
so you get the idea like maybe that was
too much maybe you should have banked
i've got a five i'm going to roll again
uh three that's eight all together i'm
going to roll again
oh nice uh hold on
14. so i'm going to bank on 14 uh just
to get the principal have another turn
brady ah
six nice what are you gonna do you've
been burned last time but we're gonna go
again hey
take the rest i need more points to
catch you and that's all over c still on
zero um but
i mean let me make one the way the game
works i want to show the scoring here so
i'm gonna do another turn just to rub it
in your face that's a two if i bank that
that round scores me two but it adds on
to my accumulator so i've got 16 all
together
and there's variations let's go go on
then
get off the ground i want to catch your
16. but do you have the guts to trust
your intuition about what's a good score
to wait for or are you now scared
because of your i should rather not i
should roll up one every six goes should
you is that guaranteed is it no
there's a five five
he's going to go again despite the
evidence of whatever and there's a six
that's eleven
i could catch you i'm gonna go i'm gonna
take the risk i'm gonna go one more
greedy
there it is
i wish i'd rigged this it's too good oh
right well i'm gonna have a go no i'm
going i'm
i'll play on my own i'm gonna go again
and a six nine i'm gonna take a nine so
that's a nine for that term but
altogether
mental arithmetic 25 do you want to get
off the mark or are you just going to
accept this is your fate this is
unbelievable
we're going to cut to like 20 rolls
through the video
there's seven altogether you're still
going go one more
just one more
well what i like about this game with
the dice
even more than the pigs it's dead simple
right you just but the the high stakes
i've seen a classroom room of people
play this and it gets loud really
quickly people are shouting the dice is
unfair this one like it feels like it's
rigged against you i did it right and
that's the luck of a dice roll that's
why games with randomness are
interesting you cannot predict what's
going to happen what you can do
is predict what you should do
on average you've played the game you've
done
i was going to try and put it nicely
done really terribly
but that wasn't i think for a lack of
skill like
luck plays a part here so what what
strategies might you have even if they
don't pan out every time do you have any
thoughts about a strategy to play the
game well i think you were thinking of
some
if there's a one in six chance or i
think you should do
three rolls
per go okay so what i'm going to call
this is a roll strategy basically pick a
number of roles that you think is is
safe maybe three rolls is a good idea
and if you're still in after three
you're saying bank maybe that is
sensible but as soon as you pick that as
a strategy the next question is
maybe four would be better
or maybe 20 rolls would be better i
suspect both of us think nah the chance
of you getting one there is like it
feels like it's gonna outweigh any
benefit so we have an instinct about a
role strategy but the question is
for what value of n does the role
strategy work best now i'd like to
analyze this one in a minute but there's
there's another way of playing instead
of picking a rod do you know what i'm
going to say a point strategy yeah so
like i'm going to call it a score
strategy maybe you just pick a target to
get to so let's say i pick 10 and then i
just keep rolling however many rolls
until i get
at least 10. and it seems like i won't
always get 10 exactly you might get 11
because i want a nine hour two or
something that seems better now to me
yeah why i think i agree because
scores and points is what wins the game
absolutely there's our goal here and we
actually haven't talked about how to win
the game which is a bit of an error in
any game the game is compelling even
when you don't know that but
traditionally the game of pig you pick a
target to get to first to 100 wins now
you could do
10 ro 10 turns each and that'll be a
different game
but the thing with mathematical
modelling like that complicates things
and in fact playing against each other
complicates things too because you
already said i'm going to try and beat
you now if i'd done well you take more
risks that's how games work and they
should work that's what makes them
interesting but a modeling point of view
you need to go way back so this is why i
made the comment about playing on my own
if you just consider i'm just going to
play on my own which is a bit of a
strange sad game to play lockdown
appropriate perhaps you can then answer
the question of
how do i maximize my score and then you
start applying that to the game
situation so i think we should analyze
these two options the but the other
strategy option is to
uh just play until you feel lucky so
let's analyze a role strategy
even though we think that maybe the
score strategy is a healthier way a few
things about dice uh there's an average
score on dice that's helpful to know
although it's slightly different because
rolling a one doesn't get you anything
if you roll a die in this game two
things can happen that are critical one
is you roll one and you're you're out
for that turn
or you score some points so let's split
into those two um i'm gonna do a
calculation that mathematicians call an
expectation so what do you expect and
there are two outcomes one is a
one-sixth chance of rolling
the one
and we'll get zero points for the entire
term now quick mental math for you
what's the chance of you not getting
that one five and six excellent so five
six at the time will score some points
and to cut a long story short i could do
like one sixth of the time you get a two
once at the time you get three we're
just going to average it so actually if
you ignore the one the average points
you score if you score anything is four
because the average of two three four
five and six so five six at the time
you're going to score four points on
average in fact if i add these two
together we've got the probability times
the outcome plus the probability times
the outcome this is what they call a
classic expectation calculation this
tells me what i would expect to score
after one roll so and this bit is just
zero right so on average i would expect
to score five sixths of four or three
point three so that's my expectation
after one roll and i don't think it's
too difficult to do a two roll strategy
the chance that you're still in
after two rolls you've got a roll not a
one on the first roll and not a one on
the second roll and on average if you're
still in after two rolls well if you're
still in you're gonna get four points
from the first roll on average and four
points on average from the second round
it's actually eight but when we
calculate it we're going to get
something less than eight but i'm just
ignoring the zeros if i'm out i've got
nothing so the expectation for two rolls
is this 5.5 recurring
so two rolls is better than one roll and
i think we could have predicted that can
we generalize now i think i think we
should jump straight in number five
viewers are ready to generalize we're
gonna go straight to n rolls instead of
just doing three and four and working
our way up so i think you can see how
this works it's gonna be if you're still
in after end rolls we need to be not
rolling ones n times in a row so that's
the chance of me still being in and on
each turn i'm going to be scoring four
points but i've got n of those terms so
this is my formula for my expectation
after enrolls
uh and if you graph this you get a graph
that's like this
it's a nice non-trivial shape and it
definitely has a peak
and
uh what did you pick three rolls well i
have news for you
the peak happens at five
and six in fact the peak happens between
the two
now you you can't roll between but this
graph like if i plotted it just as
integers five and six give you the
highest thing it's just over eight they
expect now you can't roll five and a
half times anyway if you analyze the
role strategy it says the best expected
score is five or six roles and that
feels quite intuitive you were worrying
right at the beginning about there's a
one in six chance of getting that one
and it seems to back up that slightly
naive understanding of like maybe i
should only roll six times five or six
apparently on average gives you the same
expected outcome so what should i do in
a game five or six uh i think probably
five because it's the same expectation
for less risk and that's that's what
this graph is not showing us is that six
on average will get you the score
the same but in practice it will quite
often give you a higher score and also
more often give you zero so they sort of
balance out so i think five is maybe
saner
but it's still a problem with the role
strategy because it's not taking into
account like if you did really well on
the first three roles
you're more tempted to say i want to
keep that safe and the royal strategy
will never pick that very sensible thing
up so i think even though we can analyze
it
and five or six turns out to be good
advice if you're gonna follow it it's
not great
for how to play game because it's not
taking into account that lucky streak
when you roll three sixes and everybody
does take it into account and the maths
can take it into account we've just
we've done a naive strategy but this is
what modelling is like you do a simple
pass through and then you think right
let's go back around the modeling cycle
upgrade it so let's go for a score
strategy
and i suggested maybe aiming for a score
10 might be good and i'm curious about
your instincts about this is ten a good
thing to aim for do another piece of
paper yeah i do i think for the score
strategy it it's surprisingly difficult
to calculate the expectation if i aim
for a score of ten
i think we all know like sometimes i
will get ten or a bit more than ten and
sometimes i get zero so the average is
going to be probably a bit less than 10.
so intuitively we can guess that it's a
bit less than 10 but if i aim for a
score of 50
i'm very unlikely to get it so most of
my turns are going to be zero but once
in a while boom i get 50. so where does
the average go then it's really not
intuitive and it's really hard to
calculate but what we can do
is
figure out what the best score to aim at
is by considering
individual scores not getting the
expectation just getting if i'm on a
score of 10 what will happen if i choose
to roll again so let's try 10 as our
example so aiming for 10 means if i get
anywhere above 10 i will bank if i'm on
a score of 10 let's ask what happens
next so just like before one-sixth of
the time you're gonna get zero five
sixth of the time i'm gonna score some
points and on average that's gonna be
four points
except i've already got ten
so i think if i'm on a score of ten and
i choose to roll again
my expectation of the next role this is
not saying what will i eventually get
but if i'm on 10 on a roll again this is
my expectation
and it'd be four plus
10.
so we could calculate this
zero is obvious again i get 11.6
okay now what does that mean
well 11.6 is higher than 10.
for me that means
if i want to score a 10 and i don't roll
again i'm going to get 10. like that's
obvious if i do roll again on average
i'll get 11.6
so it sounds to me like i should roll
again like it's higher so if i try
another score let's try 30
if i'm on 30 the calculation is dead
simple 5 6 of the time the zero i'm
going to ignore i'm going to get 4 plus
30.
so i can calculate that and already the
instincts are kicking anything maybe
i've been a bit greedy if i try and wait
till i get 30 and indeed i get
28.3
and that
is less than that
so if i bank on 30 i've got 30. if i
roll again on average i'll end up with
28. so my point is that somewhere these
scores will equalize
and i think at that point we've got an
indication of a good target score to aim
at but before we do the calculation i
mean
number five viewers are probably got
their paper ready to go let's try a
couple of simulations so i've got a
jojoba simulator for greedy pig here
it's actually simulating a strategy so
up here i've got aim for 10. and let's
i'm just going to
click start and it will start aiming for
10 and banking if it ever gets it just
repeatedly starting from zero rolls
yes and so you can see some bars
appearing so if i get 10
or more it gives me a bar and there's a
couple turns i got zero and it's going
to go off into the distance here um and
the yellow line is what i'm scoring on
average all the turns it's tried it and
you can see it's
it's a bit lower than 10. so there's the
occasional zero roll but quite a lot of
the time i'm getting 10 or more but the
zeros drag that line down a bit and you
can see on average i'm getting about
seven and a half points
um so this is the calculation i didn't
do before this is the holy grail of like
what is the expectation if i aim for 10
i will get about 7.98
and i know that that is accurate um
although it's actually a little bit high
and i need to do thousands of these
rolls to get in to get properly and what
i'd love to do is find a theoretical way
of doing this more on that later because
what this didn't take into account was
that the probability that you even got
to 10 in the first place exactly it's
like if you're on 10 and you roll again
then it's a good thing but hey how
likely is it that you get to 10 and
that's a difficult calculation but what
we can do is test other strategies so
let's stop and reset this if i aim for a
really high one i'm actually going to go
higher than our 30 like they're going to
go up to 50. and i think we know it's
probably a bad way to play the game so
just take a moment what we're going to
expect here once in a while we're going
to see
a bar that goes up to 50. like i have to
change the scale it's going to go really
high but when i say once in a while it's
probably
really rarely going to happen so i'm
going to start it before it takes us
ages most of the time we're going to get
zero
and what's also annoying in this is it
takes ages to run a turn because it's
basically rolling a dice lots of times
to get up to 50. and i'm a bit nervous
we're never gonna get a score we're
we're already at nine to ten turns and
i've not scored 50. oh there we go i've
got 50. uh so that was like one in 10
chance of doing you see my average has
is terrible it's like three per turn
because only once if i scored loads of
points and the rest time got zero let's
see if you get another one there is oh
yeah i mean this is we're just going to
play this for the rest of the video is
that okay i'm totally i'm obsessed there
are two things here first of all the our
instinct is backed up by the simulation
the average is low
even though you're being super
optimistic it just doesn't work out in
your favor
i'll shout if we get another one don't
worry um
but
i wanted to go quicker so i need to
write a better piece of script i should
do it in python probably rather than
jojoba so we don't get the visuals
clogging up and slowing the thing down
and nobody would play like this
but we already know that probably
somewhere between aiming for 10 and
aiming for 30 is a good score you've got
two 50s early on and you haven't got any
sense what are the chances
i'm so gonna get a 50 in real life yeah
if you film that i will i will yeah i'll
be impressed
let's just try one in between if we
wanted to guess somewhere between so i'm
going to stop it
and we'll aim for i don't know something
like 19 let's see if that works any
better so i'm just going to set this
going and if you aim for 19 like
sometimes you're not going to get it but
i've got a couple there and i'll draw
and already my average is about five or
six i've got three in a row there yeah
that was nice
um and you see that the average is is
kind of bouncing around a lot you need a
lot of data for this to smooth out it's
quite surprising how long it takes to
sort of regularize here so there's got
to be a better way
and we can go back to our calculations
to find it i mean 19 feels about right
the average is pretty good 7.8 7.4 maybe
it was as good as 10 i have a feeling
that when we're aiming for 10 we were
getting a bit lucky
um
more tens than was expected because 10
isn't very high
and
maybe you should wait longer so we're
going to solve the equation to find out
the best and gainful
back to the the actual mass the crucial
thing is we want to find the score where
if we roll again we've kind of reached
the balance point it's not higher and
it's not lower
so i'm going to change the score we're
on for
n generalizing and we want to solve this
expression
that's my expected score if i roll again
you can see how the the numbers have
sort of changed and we want it to be
bigger
than the score among
so this is a lovely sort of gcse uk 16
year old qualification
inequality to solve so we're just going
to go ahead and solve it and you can you
can check my maths and correct me
mess it up ready i'm going to multiply
both sides by 6 and that's positive so
we're okay with that that gives me 6n
there i'm going to multiply out this
bracket to get 20 plus 5 n greater than
6n
take away 5 n from both sides 20 greater
than n i'm going to swing this round
that's my headline
and the whole thing was that i was
claiming this line this is describing
when i should roll again when my
expected score is bigger than what i'm
currently on
and that translates into you roll again
if n is less than 20 which means that 20
is where you start
getting too risky to risk rolling again
and 20 is a good score to aim at
and if we tried 20 on here i guarantee
we'd get a pretty good average but it
takes a long time so what i did um so i
was playing right before you're playing
pretty well the um
aiming like you can see how this matches
the role strategy five roles
on an average score of four gives you a
score of 20. so they kind of at least
they agree with each other even though i
think this is a better way to play
because if you get 20 early bank it and
if you get if you roll lots of twos stay
in a bit longer because it's not worth
like banking out too early so i think
this is almost for the simple game
you're not playing against someone else
aim for 20 is a good piece of advice on
playing pick
i realize we can't translate this to
past the ps yet because i don't know the
prophecies of picks but we'll come back
to that a couple of other things to show
i've got a lot of data on this i've
asked a lot of school kids to play this
game and give me some data so i'll show
you the graph of what they've aimed for
a bunch of different target scores this
data
is from over a thousand students trying
this game like when we're doing lockdown
we we run this as an online session and
everyone was like submitting their data
on google forms i've got the graph and
you can see different target scores
along here
and their average score and you can see
that it's kind of backing us up here
there's some surprises so aiming for a
low score doesn't do well on average but
it doesn't do disastrously
thing is if you aim for a score two
quite often you're gonna roll a six one
and six at the time in fact and so
you're gonna do a lot better than
actually getting two but it doesn't like
balance the risk and reward whereas
aiming a bit higher gives a better
average but over here it's just really
messy and i think this is an artifact of
data
just not enough data
so i hinted at earlier what we really
want is not a thousand school kids we
want millions of roles probably done by
computer simulation so i challenged my
innermouth parker and dusted off my
python and wrote a simulation so i'm
just going to show you the simulation of
a million roles
for each target score strategy and we'll
see if it backs up
our theoretical one
this is a glimpse of my code i don't
think i'm going to put it on github
because it embarrasses me when people
comment on my lack of comments in code
but here's the video that it produced um
this is after one turn i did i did do a
million uh but just to stay like after
one turn at each of these you can see
that a score of 40 did right it's got
over 40 points it fluked it most of the
other high targets are zero so that is
not there and i've got a little podium
first second third and that's going to
move as we go the first 20 turns go
quite slow and then it will speed up so
here's a million rolls of the game of
pig
and
you see like even after five turns
there's a whole region that's never
scored anything and maybe that's because
it's too risky but the 36 is doing
inexplicably well let's carry on a bit
more
so now we're on let's get up to 20 tons
and i think everything's pretty much off
the mark
by then
but like it's such a mess there's no way
i could pull out any sort of reliable
data so i'm just going to let this go
we'll go all the way up to a million it
does go a bit quicker and i love how
spiky the graph is and how it settles
down after a thousand turns it's already
better than the data we've got i don't
know how reliable the students were at
the data python is doing better although
it's using pseudorandom numbers so gotta
trust that already the shape is settling
down and we can see that 20 is doing
pretty well although it's not on the
podium for some inexplicable reason
aiming really high on average does okay
it's just that most of the time you're
getting nothing so it's really
depressing
20 is now on the top of the leaderboard
we've done 200 000 turns 21 and 22 doing
well and close behind but the first
observation is that it's not a lot
better than aiming for 21.
but at least the mass is being backed up
by the simulation there's a weird
artifact at the beginning these two
first bars are level uh
i'm not going to comment on why i think
i do know why but people might want to
have a think about that
and after a million turns i think we're
there now
20 did win in my simulation
which i'm very relieved about
closely followed by 19 and 21 uh in the
other order in fact but all the others
nearby did pretty well so in fact this
is backing up if we actually aim for
around 20 you're gonna do all right
and maybe start to get a glimpse of how
to play the game against a player better
because if you know 20 is roughly where
you want to be you then compensate with
the other story like are they way ahead
of you in which case risk a bit more are
you way ahead maybe back off a bit now i
did do the calculation for the actual
expectation so this is experimentation
if you want to calculate what you expect
happen if you aim for 20 you need the
probability of getting to 20
in lots of dice rolls and it's
ridiculously complicated it's a
partition problem how many ways can you
add up numbers to get to
and these are the numbers from two to
six in fact
uh and it this explodes really quickly
um so so did you roll ten twos or did
you roll four or five and you very
quickly if you start counting just the
ways of getting to six even it's quite
big the number of ways of doing it so i
ran a script on python to try and
calculate some of this it got to 22
by running over a weekend
and i couldn't get it to go any further
now it's probably inefficient coding but
the size of the problem made me chuckle
because there's a much easier way just
run a million simulations and like
mathematicians being allowed to do what
they call monte carlo simulation it just
makes me smile is that there's an easier
way just try the thing and computers
help us do that so i did plot the
expectation calculations so this these
dots are the theoretical values now i'm
really pleased that they match now that
i got a 22 i claimed the the dots after
22 or 23 are
a fiction from me i made up the curve
that i think roughly followed it in fact
i used the roll calculation to get an
approximate curve of what's going on
and i think they're a bit high based on
the the actual
simulation so that's the game of pig aim
for 20.
trouble is when you play against a real
player
your instincts changed right and you're
already commenting i want to i want to
catch up with you because when you're
aiming for a target that's quite low
like a hundred
if there's some vagary that's
advantaging you you're having a lucky
day i need to adjust my strategy to try
and catch you and if for example i'm on
let's say 90
and you're on i don't know 40 like
conceivably happen
and it's your turn next what instincts
would you have
go big yeah like go big or go home
because if you give me another turn i'm
probably gonna win like the game is
probably over for you
but you have a chance you must take it
so aiming for 20 would be stupid you'd
end up on 60. bank and i win so you go
for something crazy like could you get
60 points to steal the win and that's
why the game gets exciting but
mathematically analyzing that is hard
because
you've got three variables i think
you've got the score you're on which we
kind of talked about but then you've got
the score
the other person's on which does affect
how you play
and the target you're aiming but let's
just say that's 100.
so then what some mathematicians in
america did is realize that you can
analyze this it's todd neller and
clifton presser and i dropped them an
email to ask them about this game and
they found a way to definitively answer
the question of what's the best way to
play the best way to play is to bear in
mind the 20 and like that their opening
line is like we all know the 20 is the
best way to play
and then they're like how do you take
into account this is background the
cycle how do you upgrade the model to
take around the psychology of playing
against a human how close to winning are
they and this is a process called value
iteration what they realize is that
every position like your score versus
their score versus uh what you're
currently rolling
has like a value which is basically how
likely are you to win from that position
but each of those values depends on
which other positions you can get to and
how valuable those positions are they're
all interconnected they set up a vast
system of equations
and this process called value iteration
is where you you pick a random value for
all of those positions
and you force them by running it through
a calculation again to converge on what
the values must be until it's close
enough so you don't get precise answer
but you get a converging iteration and
they basically ended up with a
three-dimensional graph of how to play
the game and to cut long story short let
me show you the graph this
looks daunting right so but let's just
talk about the i'll show you another
viewing of it but there's there's your
score along here
and the opponent's score along here so
it's always done from player one's point
of view
and the vertical axis is the turn total
that you're currently on the one you
have control over and the rest is in the
bank
uh here's another view of it from the
other side um first of all there's this
weird like the first thing you notice is
playing
and that's because if you're on a score
of 90 there is no point in you rolling
more than 10 because you finished the
game if you want to go on 80 roll for
20. right so that is 100 minus x
actually that that's sort of the line of
that plane that's why there's that sort
of
starting obvious thing but then it's
surprisingly bumpy and non-smooth and
all over the place and there's some
overhangs and that's just weird so let's
look at one little cross section here so
i'm going to pull out the
cross section of
when
the opponent is on a score of 30. so
imagine you're playing against me brady
i'm on
and 100 is a win 100 is a win
and if you're on zero and i'm a 30 what
would you do
go big why because i need to make up
lost ground and so you can see there's
this line here the black line is
indicating like what you should aim for
and it's just a there's a dotted line at
20 which we know is like default
behavior sensible
but you should aim higher than 20. not a
lot higher because you don't want to
lose it all but aim a bit higher to
catch up
and the gray region in the background
saying that that score is likely to
happen if both players are playing
optimally and then there's a region
where it's white but there's still a
black line it's all above 20.
and if you're on a score of 30 and i'm
on a score of 30 what would your
instincts be
stick to the normal strategy right and
that's because the black line is bang on
20 at that point
what's surprising is that in between
when you start looking right like it
starts to go up and down so sometimes
you should be aiming higher than 20
because you're behind
but if you are really far ahead
i don't know if you're on a score of 60
i'm on 30 what would you do what this
algorithm is saying is that you're far
enough ahead that you can back off the
risk so aim for below 20 in fact the
line is about 18.
uh what's strange is that as soon as you
get uh to about 60 there's another
overhang here
which means that first of all i think
the first line is crossed you should
bank at about 16 you're far enough ahead
don't take the risks cruise to the
finish
but if you didn't stop at 16 and you
start getting a big score there comes a
point when you're on 95 should you keep
going
the risk of losing it is outweighed by
the fact you might win on the next roll
so there's the overhang kicking in it's
like actually if you keep going even
though we told you to stop
then it starts to make sense ah just go
for it now if you're way ahead you can
see it goes all the way down you can aim
for like a as lower score as about 10 in
this case if you're on about 75.
after that you go about past 75 you're
like just go for broke no you're too
close to finish and i love that that all
that psychology which we have an
intuitive feel has been solved
mathematically to back it up and fair
play to todd and clifton who wrote the
math to do that and have this lovely
preaching of beautiful three-dimensional
graphs which i just i just love this
animation
and what it also means is kind of the uh
to bring this full circle is that
they've done the analysis on the simple
game
they can do the analysis
on the real game all that's missing
is the probabilities
of how these pigs roll i mean we could
do it if they hadn't done it but a
school in america had a school project
at one point but the whole class i think
they had a week off work they rolled
these pigs thousands of times and
recorded what positions they landed in
and todd and clifton were like
our work is done
plug those numbers into our value
iteration thing and they've got a 3d
graph for how to play
past the pigs
so i'm not going to give the secrets
away too much you can go and read their
paper i think it's a nice bit of digging
but there's an optimal
there's sort of the basic thing to aim
for based on the scoring here and
taking into account how close to the
finish you are how close to the finish
your opponent is here's the graph of
past the pigs it's slightly differently
colored but i just really like it
there's some other subtleties going on
with two different layers here but first
thing to notice is it's quite a similar
looking graph to our game
but it is at different values same axis
though that that's uh player two score
here player one score
there and the vertical is your turn
total and what they've done they're also
on their website you can go and find
this out follow the link to the paper
they've also analyzed all the other
variants there's loads of variants like
maybe you lose on a six instead of on a
one hey we can figure out strategy for
that now uh all the variants of other
sort of marketed games with different
variations too i really like this it's
like a triumph of mathematical modelling
based on a game that we can all
understand and we have some instinct
about
and there's like lots of iterations of
how much better can we train our
intuition with a bit of mathematics some
of it's high school maths gives you a
first glimpse some of it's more than
high school maths but is is graspable
and the paper's about it and uh todd and
clifton have programmed especially with
another colleague of this they're
programmed an online pig player so you
can go and play against the optimal pig
player online
and see if you can beat it well there's
no chance i'll beat it
brady your luck may change
then again
it may not
this episode was supported by kiwico
get one of these boxes of genius
delivered to your doorstep and channel
your inner engineer now i know these are
mainly for a younger demographic but
basically you can choose your box from
the site as you can see here and
everyone's catered for even me
i always think i'm bit of a numpty when
it comes to making stuff like this but
seriously even i could handle it
and i kind of felt a real sense of
achievement putting it all together
it's fun but it also pulls back the
curtain on all sorts of science and tech
art mathematics engineering all that
good stuff
now i'm being a little bit greedy doing
it myself
but i can see how a subscription to
kiwico would go down very well with
numerous members of my family could be a
birthday present taken care of here and
a special offer get fifty percent of
your first month by going to kiwico
dot com slash number five the url is
there on the screen and also down in the
description and there is my animation
machine
not bad not bad at all
[Music]
so you can look at a different version
of the game instead of a d6
one is a d8
and instead of losing on a one you could
say lose on anything else i'm gonna say
you lose on a one or two